I worked with Harry on the first One
Direction record we used to live at uh
this guy Chris Leonard um had a uh a
flat and Fulham and I remember but
before I had money from my album my
album went number one and Harry had gone
number one with What Makes You Beautiful
that day same day and we were both
staying at Chris's house I've always
rooted for him and I always like think
that I just think it's amazing going
from the biggest boy band in the world
and then going rebuilding it coming back
with three amazing album albums winning
album The Year the Grammy and then going
back into stadiums it's just it's a
really really impressive Journey